[Musique]
il
bien le bonjour chez vous aujourd'hui
nous sommes au bord de la mer noire dans
la magnifique ville de sotchi
situé au sud de la russie au pied des
montagnes du caucase
cette ville fait partie de l'empiré
russe depuis 1829 suite à la guerre
russo turque
elle a conquis le coeur des russes
devenant ainsi la station balnéaire la
plus prisée du pays
c'est surtout grâce à la localisation
c'est la ville la plus septentrionale et
sub tropical au monde
[Musique]
néanmoins la ville et m et non pas
seulement par les amateurs des plages
mais aussi par les skieurs en 1h30 vous
êtes au pied des montagnes skis aux
pieds
c'est ici qu'ont lieu les jeux
olympiques d'hiver de 2014 qui a permis
à la ville d'avoir l'attention du monde
entier
aujourd'hui entre la formule 1 la coupe
du monde de football de 2018 la ligue
internationale de hockey
cette ville de près de 400 mille
habitants accueille habituellement
chaque année plus de 4 millions de
visiteurs
[Musique]
l'un des endroits les plus appréciés de
la ville est le quai c'est justement ici
que se trouve la brigantine la brasserie
de notre invité martial simoneau allons
faire sa connaissance
[Musique]
bono maire comment tu vas tu as eu le
plaisir de tous
ouais ça va écoute cheminer avec lui
avec le soleil j'ai tellement envie de
de profiter un petit peu se chient la
mer le soleil
j'avais commandé c'est toi qui l'a
commandé comme à nice comme à nice j'ai
pas pu visiter et dégoûter tous les mecs
que tu fais dans ta dans sa brasserie
j'aimerais bien que tu montres un petit
peu ce que là-bas on bat à la brasserie
d'accord en ôta panorama c'est le
restaurant
ok tu à nice c'est la pâtisserie et gino
gelato scénographe plan c'est pourquoi
ici et qu'est ce qu'est ce qui fait que
c'est unique
ben parce que premièrement je suis
français c'est un endroit c'est une
place où on fait la cuisine française
rien de plus et puis bon bah regarde le
climat ce matin les gens et car il s et
y déjeuner à 8h regarde sur la terrasse
en mangeant des croissants français 1
n'a pas à se plaindre ton petit code
francs 6,6 à 5,6 et savais tu me montres
un petit peu là comment ça se passe bah
ouais bien chez moi qui viens voir allez
vas-y surface
[Musique]
bon bah alors un compte ou un petit peu
de temps restant à ben voilà ça
super bon bah petites salles et or du
voyeur et un petit point de l'isma port
de nice
on va pas se plaindre je vois là bas et
un portrait de toit basse et le
président
cette pause ils ont vu que je suis à
créditer kremlin disons que le président
peut venir manger ici dimanche il a
cette fusion medvedev
ah oui il est venu manger ici depuis mon
ça m'est arrivé de mesfar roger chez lui
est-ce qu'il a des préférences si tu
n'as pas droit me dire secret d'état
c'est un bon mangeur un moment j'ai bien
mangé et il a le goût
[Musique]
et donc là on fait des glaces naturels
sans colorants alors tu as tous les
parfums en ce moment c'est calme c'est
début de la saison donc on est on n'a
pas tout normalement c'est archi plein
bien que toute façon les russes même au
mois de décembre
il mange des glaces sa part un problème
il n'ya pas intérieur de croissants la
barre au dessus au dessus et à la
pâtisserie tu ne rentres tu veux
vraiment
[Musique]
alors là je te montre un petit peu voici
tel boulangerie ouais mais bon je vais
pâtisseries tout ça les russes aiment
beaucoup le rucher gourmand il aime il
ya les muscs et ben on savait à temps
comme les français on va pas croire
s'est pas fait est-ce que c'était
difficile pour toi d'ouvrir un
restaurant
quinze jours on fait sa société deux
jours pour la banque
et puis ensuite
le personnel du personnel et le lui
apprendre à travailler
par contre ça prendrait ça prend du
temps je prends que des jeunes comme ça
genre apprend et on va parler et trouver
les ingrédients sur place
sur place c'est peut-être faut pas trop
rêver hein
ou est-ce que tu prépares c'est lionel
bah oui j'ai la peau
la piscine c'est de la bombe
[Musique]
français sont réputés pour leur
classicisme moi je ne connaissais pas ce
type de plat et voilà il m'a formé
[Musique]
je suis arrivé ici encore tout jeune
fille et c'est lui qui m'a appris à
travailler selon céret il m'a vraiment
entraîné à cela sa collègue
il a une riche expérience il est passé
par beaucoup de choses il nous donne
souvent des conseils de vie très juste
on est jeune et on les ignore mais après
on comprend qu'il a raison
[Musique]
et
martial habite un appartement situé non
loin de son restaurant il nous propose
de nous recevoir chez lui avec sa
compagne helena
tu mon ton appartement là moi ça
m'intéresse c'est un petit coup dans mon
petit ambésiens je te présente ma petite
maman vous souhaitiez
alors qu'est ce que tu veux voir là où
tu as vu un peu que c'est magnifique tu
as une vue superbe tu vas me raconter
bien détail en plus on est on est con et
à combien de minutes la du restaurant
quand on n'a même pas dix minutes on a
400 mètres à pied
ouais c'est bien ça tous les matins ça
te fait oui c'est non je fais un petit
détour et ce prêt parce que c'est trop
beau trop pour moi j'adore marcher au
moins tu devrais pas avec les autobus à
rien non non puis moi je suis bien je
passe dans les jardins en bas c'est
magnifique ça à plaisir et tu vois j'ai
plus de fenêtres que muricy d'accès pas
c'est quand même une de ses quartiers ce
qu'on a c'est grave fait gaffe talent à
tous les jours une loi alors on acquis
aujourd'hui on a une tortue une tortue
il ya un mais qui ont bien là le chat il
ya le shaq est là bas le chien qui est
là des petits personnages
il ya du monde sorti de la famille cela
et y situe à louer tu as acheté comment
ça se passe j'ai acheté 8 9 ans ici en
russie les mansardes ça vaut moins cher
que les combats en dessous que les
appartements du tout c'est parce que les
sens fort marche pas ou il ment non
c'est parce que les russes n'aiment pas
spécialement les mansardes les mansardes
c'est comme à paris mais ici ça fait un
peu pauvre alors que moi les mansardes
ici bon et bien on est aux dernières
étapes
j'ai juste la sainte vierge suédois
bon tu vis ici en russie et l'ue revient
un peu en france quand même de temps en
temps eh ben les locaux vides ça va
faire parce que deux ans je suis pas
rentré mais donc sinon je romps une ou
deux fois par an parce que janot j'ai un
de mes fils qu'étant à nice donc je
rentre pour lui dire bonjour quand même
ça te manque pas un petit peu la france
en dix ans quand je reviens moi une
chose qui est importante c'est tout de
suite je m'achète un pain de campagne
ouais des rillettes des petites
crevettes grises du ah bon camembert bon
cadeau ce qui pue et puis un petit coup
de pinard avec et je suivrai trop petit
péché mignon c'est ça ben voila quand
même
pour moi le plaisir c'est aussi quand
même il ya trois choses importantes dans
la vie c'est pour moi une bonne bouffe
du bon pinard et une femme sympathique
voilà après tu es loin
qu'est-ce que tu as comme hobby qu'est
ce que tu fait de tes journées ans je
travaille tous les jours trouve tous les
jours tous les jours pas une journée de
congé tous les jours c'est mon plaisir
c'est un hobby c'est tout ce travail
c'est la même chose ça mais moi je ne
travaille pas je me fais plaisir si tu
fais un travail
1 sinon bah je marche beaucoup de marge
ouais et ici ce qui est bien en russie
la sécurité tu peux te promener le soir
minuit deux heures trois heures le matin
tu es un homme tu es une femme tu te
promènes en toute tranquillité et
étendue un personne va tomber tes genoux
avec un piano là bas bah disons qu
arrive à un certain âge il faut quand
même comme tu dis avoir des lobbys donc
je me suis dit faut bien je n'en trouva
donc je me suis dit je vais je vais
apprendre le piano
alors en ce moment j'apprends de piano
ça fait sept mois que je suis dessus à
essayer de déchiffrer ont bon an mal an
on est en arrive mais bon bah je pense
un pas la musique tous à la musique soit
pas bon j'aime bien le blues j'essaye le
beau jeu
boogie j'ai la main gauche mais pas la
main droite 1 c'est en ce moment je suis
sur les feuilles du boogie ouais j'suis
sûr la même chose sur les feuilles
mortes là ça va j'arrive bientôt a
encore quinze jours les poux je pourrais
jouer
[Musique]
tu animes le restaurant en temps en
temps tu viens de piano je manie moi jen
haute et je m'énerve tout seul c'est
bien mais c'est bien il n'y a pas d'âge
pour apprendre de toute façon un bon
produit tous et toutes façons quand on
n'a plus de projet c'est qu'on est déjà
mort c'est quoi les prochains projets en
russie va ainsi lui être heureux oui
c'est vrai bien ici on est bien
ah ouais ça fait 22 ans que la 22e en
russie sinon si on n'est pas bien on
s'en va
[Musique]
marcia simoneau est né en 1954 dans le
calvados dès son enfance il aide sa mère
qui tient un petit café resto les
modestes moyens de ses parents ne lui
permettent pas de rentrer dans une école
hôtelière et il commence à travailler à
16 ans au casino de devis ils montent
rapidement à paris où il officie dans un
restaurant petit mais très côté où il
voit passer des artistes célèbres plus
tard il est embauché au prestigieux café
de la paix où il monte petit à petit
tous les échelons jusqu'à devenir maître
d'hôtel curieux de tout il fréquente
aussi les cuisines afin d'apprendre les
secrets des chaînes en 1997
martial des ménages à nice où il est
chef cuisinier dans son propre
restaurant
après cette première expérience à son
compte il est invité par des clients
russes pour ouvrir un restaurant de
grand standing au centre de moscou et il
décide de tenter la grande aventure pour
partir en russie
en 1999 après plusieurs expériences dans
différentes villes de russie au cours
desquelles ils travaillent pour des
employeurs prestigieux martial décide de
s'installer dans le sud du pays
c'est en 2008 qu'il ouvre son propre
restaurant à krasnaya polyana dans une
station de ski proche de sotchi
al'annonce des jeux olympiques d'hiver à
sotchi il voit défiler chez lui un bon
nombre d'officiels ainsi que l'élite
russe
à la veille des jeux olympiques en
échange de son restaurant dans les
montagnes il se voit proposer une
pâtisserie à sotchi qu'il va même
transformé en une brasserie la
brigantine situé qui plus est sur le
port de la ville
martial vit dorénavant avec sa compagne
helena sur les hauteurs de la ville où
il reçoit de temps en temps ses deux
fils ainsi que ses petits-enfants de
nice ou de sotchi
[Musique]
nous avons décidé de nous balader dans
l'une des communes de sotchi qui
s'appelle adler autrefois c'était le
coeur des jeux olympiques est devenu
aujourd'hui le lieu préféré des
promenades des petits et des grands
l'art martial nous sommes ici dans le
centre olympique qui l'ont bien connu
c'est ça alors qu'ils n'avaient rien
c'était un marécage où il ya des très
belles fleurs on venait me promener ici
du coup il y avait personne au
tranquille en arrivant parce que je
crois que j'ai travaillé je ne savais
pas qu'il y avait les chiots qui à
l'arrivée c'est pas pour ça que non non
moi je ne savais pas moi j'ai loué le un
restaurant et six mois après il ya eu on
a signalé comme les jeux olympiques je
fus là au bon moment c'est tout sata
importé je dirais enfin quand tu l'a
appris tu t'es dit tiens je souhaite que
quand je me suis dit
ce que j'avais pensé faire ici ça va
être différent parce que là ça va
booster la veille avoir de la voyante
celle là pour le faire une maison de
retraite là je vais faire un truc qui
est qui booste et le sotchi donc d'avant
et le sotchi d'aujourd'hui versés rien à
voir suit une nouvelle ville
[Musique]
et quand tu compares aujourd'hui je sais
pas si on parle de nice et de sotchi
parce que si j'ai bien compris on a la
même latitude on a le même latitude mais
bon c'est tout ce qui entre les deux
mêmes latitudes shanxi ses sushis nice
et nice ils ont leurs qualités leur
avantage c'est différent on y vit bouge
enfin moi je vis bien sotchi depuis 15
ans
j'ai donc là on a bien profité gens ils
me paient
[Musique]
le soir tombe il est déjà l'heure du
dîner je salive d'avancé à l'idée que
martial va me faire goûter ses huîtres
alors ce soir dégustation d'huîtres oui
raconteront un petit peu reculer
tu les a trouvés ici que les fermières
de france doit bien avant tout donné de
france après l'embargo de france est
parti en tunisie de tunisie est allé
jusqu'à estampillé tunisienne est arrivé
à moscou
ok maintenant les russes l'embargo alors
a fait du bien parce que maintenant ils
font plein de choses en russie et on
trouve des huit en russie donc là tu vas
voir des opérateurs cd8 qui viennent de
nouveaux stocks et à côté de ça tu vas
manger
18 des fines de claire française des
petits dessins qui sont ils ont fait
venir de france et s'agrandit en crimée
donc ici à cause de clés les fameuses
huîtres franco tient les voilà qui à
harry chorus carrément vu ce mélange
odilon c'est magnifique on sera en
france on essaye un merci romain
merci reciva
alors est-ce que les est ce que les
russes aiment les huîtres hier c'était
quelque chose de nouveau pour eux
comment disons qu'il ya vingt ans en
arrière quand je suis arrivé les russes
connaissaient les huit mais ça date pas
de maintenant ça date 2014 il y avait
des huîtres de cancale way qui partait
jusqu'en russie et à s'appeler des arts
sky elles sont très bonnes elles sont
peut-être aussi salée finalement à bonon
enfin c'est comme les moules les moules
qu'on en mer noire
elles sont moins salée que celle de
français est ce que tu as des soucis
peut-être un impôt du sanitaire en fait
comment ça se passe ici est ce que c'est
beau la russe a un coût du sérieux c'est
quand tu arrives à en russie quand je
suis arrivé j'avoue que bon déjà faute
changer un peu ta façon de penser parce
que la logique en russie n'est pas la
même qu'en europe d'accord normal mais
quand tu travailles avec
il travaille sur des bases qui datent de
staline un plus c'est un autre problème
c'est que je pourrais avoir par exemple
des moules maintenant mais moi j'ai
besoin d'un certificat sans certificat
sanitaire
je prends pas je peux prendre le risque
mais imagine que je rende à quelqu'un
malade alors là oui j'ai intérêt d'avoir
ma valise paraître quel plat à se situe
le plus à la russie je dirais le boersch
et les pires min le principal c'est
qu'en cuisine c'est de le faire avec le
coeur et une grand-mère qui te fait un
bortsch avec le coeur il est toujours
bon qu'est ce qui t'a marqué le plus en
russie j'avoue qu'un quelque chose qui
m'a marqué c'est la gentillesse des gens
une chose qui est importante en russie
que par exemple je suis né en normandie
si un normand t'invite à la maison ils
invitent sur le pas de la porte en
russie quand tu aimes bien on invite
honte ouvre la porte
la table ils feront le maximum pour la
garnir et tu vois que c'est le coeur et
l'âme roues ce qui douche à la bruce la
bruce cliquez sur la table et ça j'avoue
que j'avais oublié écoute c'est un grand
merci pour ton accueil pour son
hospitalité sénat fera vous a fait
énormément plaisir aussi de fait plaisir
doit recevoir ici et puis il ya que du
bonheur il sait qu'il veut
merci encore de cas à a
[Musique]
notre journée touche à sa fin nous
n'avons passé avec un homme authentique
maciel simoneau qui nous a présenté sa
station balnéaire sotchi ainsi que son
petit coin de france sa brasserie
de nouveaux lieux de nouveaux invités
tout aussi intéressant vous attendre je
vous dis à très bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
je